the biden white house cracking down on
freedom of speech just days after elon
musk's twitter takeover coincidence dhs
secretary major is announcing plans for
what he calls a disinformation
governance board to combat
misinformation ahead of the midterms
we have just established a miss and
disinformation governance board in the
department of homeland security to more
effectively
combat
this threat not only to election
security but to our homeland security it
sounds like the objective of the board
is to prevent disinformation and
misinformation from traveling around the
country in a range of communities i'm
not sure who opposes that effort
i smell a rat the group will be led by a
far-left russia expert who called hunter
biden's laptop quote a trump campaign
product in 2020 some expert she's also
been vocal about her disdain for elon
musk saying she shudders to think about
the billionaire taking over twitter
anti-musk fever practically a
prerequisite for any job in the white
house as more democrats pile on the
world's richest man and his love of free
speech liz warren taking another shot
last night
we need rules of the road and look
they're going to be rules like i said
the only question is will
elon musk decide all the ruling rules by
himself in a dark room or is it going to
be the case that we're going to decide
this as a country we're going to make
rules in a democracy rules of the road
could help facilitate that kind of
competition and frankly break the
stranglehold of someone like elon musk
coming in and just owning the whole
thing
he'll say anything for wampum
judge
what a coincidence that this is just
happening this week
it has to there's no connection
whatsoever to the elections or
or elon musk
i agree with you it is a coincidence but
you know on the other side you have to
say to yourself isn't it amazing how
fast they got this disinformation group
together i mean given how long it took
them to uh get weapons to the ukraine
right really even with zielinski saying
it's a pity and that's zelinski's words
they didn't get the weapons to us or
given how disorganized they were and
getting out of afghanistan and just as
an aside why didn't they take think
about taking the weapons from
afghanistan and give them to ukraine
that would have been a smart idea but
look this whole thing is very organized
you got barack obama an ex-president of
the united states coming out and saying
we want content moderation now you've
got these people saying we're going to
have a disinformation group where we can
say what we think is not correct and you
know we suffered under their thumb for
four years of the russian collusion
delusion uh along with the uh the the
the uh biden hunter biden laptop being
russian disinformation i mean they have
lied to us repeatedly but you know the
only thing that they want is they want
to be able to control what we say and
what we say to each other and what we
think so their hatred of elon musk i
mean it is palpable see joey reid last
night we talked about you know he just
misses the apartheid of south africa
elizabeth warren think of what they're
doing to him behind the scenes if
they're doing this right in front of
everybody and it's real clear the
constitution of the united states allows
for free speech no government has the
right to moderate define or limit free
speech that is in the constitution it is
a first amendment for a reason and it is
affirmed by the supreme court over and
over again and their efforts to muzzle
us under the claim of free speech unless
it's obscenity child porn or fighting
world of words uh is really an effort to
uh control this country in a way that
we've never seen before you know it's
like jason now it's like if you are it's
if you're for free speech you're now
labeled a free speech absolutist like
that like somehow you're an extremist oh
did you hear he's an absolutist can they
what here's the thing they create this
this board what can they actually do i
mean look like could they sit and watch
the five and go greg said he bet jason
jesse a million bucks he couldn't lift
his mug he really did he doesn't really
gonna pay that million dollars is he i
mean are they actually gonna look at
like shows and see what they're doing
and do they have any authority to do
anything
i don't think they have the authority
but they're going to try um secretary
marcus he i mean he looked like he was
live from beijing telling us you know
how everybody is what they can say how
they can say it this is allowable this
is not allowable they tried this before
about 10 years or so ago it's called
sopa stop online uh piracy act there
were republicans and democrats they
tried to give homeland security
unilateral authority to take down
websites so this is a playbook that they
went to under the obama administration
uh they're trying to do it now but i
think what they're really afraid of with
elon musk is he's going to peel back and
expose what was going on with the shadow
banning about how they manipulated the
social media to be for their team on the
democratic side of the aisle and against
conservatives that's what i think
they're really afraid of and the guy is
only he's he said he's only going to be
successful if he's politically neutral
and allows democrats and republicans to
go out there
you know dana
uh
the fact that this expert or this person
in charge
you know
pushed that letter of the 50 former
national security officials called the
laptop fake uh and then and then you
have majors and it's like remember the
whip gate thing that was probably one of
the biggest uh misinformation scams how
can they pull this off like how can this
happen why why her it's interesting i've
brought this up before i remember
ainsley hayes she worked on the in the
west wing for president bartlett on the
show i never watched the show she was a
she was a republican and she worked in
they made her work in the basement and
every once in a while they would pull
her upstairs and say how do you think
the republicans are going to feel about
this and they should be like i wouldn't
do that you can do this but not that
they need an ainslie haze in the
administration because i can't imagine
that anybody at this meeting said do you
think it's going to be a problem that
she's going to be in charge of it yeah
well why would that possibly be it would
never have occurred to them so they
don't have an early warning system
but there i don't think that dhs has the
authority to do this under the
congressional act that established dhs
now it's too broad i get that but this
was certainly not included um
the thing about elon musk
he doesn't care if he's liked yeah and
it's driving the left absolutely crazy
there is a little bit of a model for
this it also doesn't work that well
although they try it's called the
broadcasting board of governors and it
was it's controversial under every
president the way they set it up is
there's four republicans and four
democrats and the chair of the board is
the secretary of state whoever that
happens to be at the time and they try
to adjudicate things
that might be a better way you can't
just have bureaucrats going to be in
charge of free speech like they've
missed the entire ministry of truth
doesn't make any sense also something
very strange is going on i'm not buying
it that all of a sudden a hundred
thousand more people decided to follow
me overnight the percy pictures are
great and all but i find that very hard
to believe i think benchmark got like
500 000 new followers something weird
was happening yeah that's true uh so
jessica if let's say this was under a
different administration and the bias
the political bias and ideology were
going in the direction you didn't like
you would be scared when i when i see
that this person is a left-winger who
who
who dismissed the the laptop before
there was even any evidence that like
she just did it because she knew that
she had to to win an election you would
be scared too you can't have a
bureaucrat with an ideology in charge of
speech shouldn't have anybody in charge
of speech
well everyone is entitled to their
ideology we're just not supposed to know
about it that's how it works you go into
a voting booth you do your business and
then you go back if you work in
government and you do you also go there
not just do your business
that is disgusting but funny yes um and
i walked right into it uh i would agree
with you she did defend
those comments by saying that she was
live tweeting the presidential debates
but obviously i've seen a lot of footage
of this you could make the case that she
certainly had more left-leaning opinions
though she does have a pretty impressive
background and was at a non-partisan
center the wilson center doing her work
she has a lot of experience in russia
and in that world she started out
working in belarus named after woodrow
wilson i believe so i know where it's
supposed to be canceled communists
anyway so
they said that the point of this is to
target misinformation about russia and
also uh the border which i think is
interesting something that should appeal
to conservatives and one of the examples
that they threw out was that um across
facebook and whatsapp in haiti they had
misconstrued what president biden had
been saying about immigration policy
saying that he was going to welcome
everybody and 14 000 haitians showed up
at a border town and we're trying to get
into the united states of america now
what the government is saying or dhs is
saying now that they want to be able to
tap into problems like that and to stop
it before another 14 000 people show up
and say hey we heard there was an open
border here we'd like to get in now in
terms of whether this is legal or within
the con you know the rights of dhs to do
i don't know they certainly feel that
way but they've been organizing this for
months this woman came out and said this
it wasn't just something happened
overnight she's not working on it fair
enough if they're organizing it for
months then the first thing they should
do is address the misconstrued reign for
whip which is a border issue while they
ignored all the concerns jessica they
went after a guy that's the first thing
that would be the example they should
have used like you know what we scr that
would have been really smart you know we
screwed up we actually produced
misinformation and disinformation we
blamed the wrong guy we did it we did
this investigation we found out guy was
innocent i would i would trust them more
would you though yes i would because
i'm an open-minded person jessica a
loving open-minded person you know um i
think we should start testing this
on the five start saying things that
they might think is disinformation just
like that you're a loving guy yes
exactly okay i want i want them to fact
check that
all right enough
she probably hates the five that lady
oh she doesn't like the fight she
doesn't like the five yeah we're gonna
have to do it you never know there's
very high liberal viewership i know a
little higher than most other places hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else